revista de prensa en directo América de
Francia 24 Marta Moya estaba como
siempre con nosotros todas las mañanas
Marta ya estamos a jueves cómo amaneció
hoy todo bien Raúl Muchas gracias Bueno
Marta muy bien y vamos a comenzar
Entonces nosotros nuestra revista de
prensa destacando un análisis que hace
el periódico español el país el cual da
los ingredientes para esta refutar no la
idea de que las potencias occidentales
están en declive sobre todo desde la
pandemia Kobe 19 o por supuesto del
conflicto que estamos viviendo
actualmente en Ucrania no que dice el
país Buenos días Raúl como decíamos
vamos a hablar de un análisis del país
hecho por el corresponsal de asuntos
globales que se llama Andrea Ricci y que
titula está en declive occidente no
tanto como muchos pensaban el concepto
del decliveoccidental ha estado al orden
en el orden del día en artículos
periodísticos en la academia en la
geopolítica y en la política
internacional en general Pero esto está
un poco en entredicho al bueno Al Calor
de los últimos acontecimientos sobre
todo en los últimos meses incluso
Vladimir Putin Hace unos días en la
ceremonia de anexión unilateral
recordemos de los cuatro territorios
ucranianos llegó a mencionar hasta en 33
ocasiones Raúl los términos occidente y
occidental y llegó a decir que el
colapso de la hegemonía occidental era
Irreversible asociaba estos conceptos
además al colonialismo la dominación
depredadora o el racismo pero hasta qué
punto es esto bien pues en el siglo XX y
en El Siglo 21 este concepto del declive
Occidental parecía establecerse con el
crecimiento de China la estabilización
de Rusia tras la caída de la unión
soviética y la concatenación de crisis
en el seno de el mundo occidental pero
podía haberse dado como un reajuste de
equilibrios globales que sin embargo
ahora podría estar
este análisis y como los ingredientes
clave de que este declillo occidental
Quizá no está el Marta pues Raúl
hablamos de ámbito militar ámbito
científico y alianzas en términos de
ámbito militar se destaca que occidente
pues ha tenido lagunas importantes
militares véase las acciones militares
de Europa en el sahel en el norte de
África or o Perdón en Libia Estados
Unidos una derrota Clara en Afganistán y
la invasión a Irak también se considera
controvertida sin embargo Pues el seno
de la otan o las alianzas occidentales
es difícil que se puedan equiparar al de
otras potencias ante lo que se creía un
gigante militar como Rusia que ha estado
dos décadas ampliando sus inversiones
militares y la modernización de estos
equipos se ha demostrado con la ayuda
Ucrania que el apoyo de Occidente
es eficaz al menos según los reportes
que tenemos por otra parte china ha
mostrado mucho músculo económico y esto
puede venir de la mano Raúl de más
inversión económica sin embargo china no
tiene la capacidad o no tiene esta
experiencia reciente en combate Hablando
ahora sí del ámbito científico
destacamos que el 19 parecía estar mucho
más a favor y controlado por china que
por occidente sin embargo con el tiempo
occidente se ha mostrado más eficaz con
las vacunas y en China Todavía están con
los confinamientos en términos de
competitividad competitividad Perdón
empresas y universidades occidente tiene
mucha más capacidad de reacción que
otras potencias hablando de alianzas
Rusia y China antes de la invasión a
Ucrania anunciaron una relación sin
límites que luego se ha visto un poco
condicionada porque china se ha puesto
de perfil con la guerra en Ucrania y
occidente dan muestras de unidad con la
Esfera de la otan y los 40 países que
defienden esas sanciones contra Moscú
rápidamente Marta vamos a cambiar de
tema porque el arranque la legislatura
en Italia tras la conformación del
Congreso y el senado con los
ultrarechistas o los partidos germanos
de Italia y la liga de mayoría ya
sacamos una entrevista que le hizo en
exclusiva el cordillera a Marín le penn
si Raúl estamos más cerca de salvini
pero meloni está en el lado correcto eso
dice la líder de agrupación nacional
Marín le penn dice que aunque la alianza
con la liga de Mateo salvini es
inquebrantable porque hasta comparten
partido en el parlamento europeo
identidad y democracia si se llama el
partido melón y también está el lado
correcto de la idea nacionalista
titulares que destaca esta entrevista a
Ale pen no destaca O sea no descarta
perdón volverse a presentar en las
elecciones francesas salvo
circunstancias excepcionales continúa
diciendo que las sanciones energéticas a
Moscú son ineficaces y matiza el envío
de armamento a Ucrania y dice que
Francia debe salirse de la otan
preguntada por un posible frente
europeísta entre braguin y macrón dice
que Europa tiene que apostar por la idea
de la Europa de las Naciones donde los
países tengan más competencias que
Bruselas Marta Gracias por toda la
información mañana como hace revista de
prensa pero que eso